oh there's this gospel statement that if
you knock the door will open and that if
you ask you will receive and if you
search you'll find if you seek you'll
find and people who are faithless in
some sense think about it as kind of a
Hallmark greeting card approach to the
world or you just ask for things and
they appear it's like no that isn't what
any of that means it means nothing that
you want will manifest itself unless you
aim for it and you won't aim for it
unless you know what it is and you won't
know what it is unless you ask yourself
and then you might say well why don't
you ask yourself and the answer is well
maybe no one ever explained to you that
you needed to which is a crucial issue
and then maybe you don't also trust
yourself